it's getting worse and worse for Donald
Trump now that Jeffrey Epstein has been
arrested for child sex trafficking I
told you before and I reminded you
yesterday that a woman has alleged that
when she was 13 years old Donald Trump
and Jeffrey Epstein raped her at
Epstein's New York City condo the
lawsuit was ultimately stopped by the
accuser after she allegedly received
death threats because she had come
forward now Donald Trump has been going
very much out of his way to distance
himself from Jeffrey Epstein as much as
possible despite having hung out with
him a lot in years past and he even
threw out somebody at his rally in
Minnesota over the weekend for holding
up a picture of Trump with his arm
around Jeffrey Epstein I talked about
that yesterday there's now a stunning
report in The New York Times which
includes the story of a 1992 party at
Donald Trump's mar-a-lago Resort in
Florida where the only attendees were
Donald Trump Jeffrey Epstein and quote
28 girls for some kind of supposed
calendar girl competition now why am i
calling them girls and not women because
that's the word that the organizer used
to describe this event his name is
George her a knee
he's a Florida businessman who ran
American dream enterprise and he
organized this party for Donald Trump
and Jeffrey Epstein saying to the New
York Times quote I arranged to have some
contestants fly in at the very first
party I said who's coming tonight I have
28 girls coming it was him and Epstein I
said Donald this is supposed to be a
party with VIPs you're telling me it's
you and Epstein and I want to be really
really careful here to make clear what I
am Telling You and what I am not telling
you or what it is that the New York
Times is reporting and what it is not
that they're reporting there is no
indication that any of these 28 women
were underage as far as what we know
right now okay this is evidence that
Donald Trump was truly friends with
Epstein liked Epstein liked hanging out
with him was hanging out with him and in
this case it was just him Epstein and 28
hired women or girls as they are
described by George her a nice so the
big pick
is very clear the party was in 1992 this
is around the same time that the doe
versus Trump incident allegedly happened
where Trump was accused of raping the
thirteen-year-old girl I got some emails
yesterday from people saying David I'm
glad you brought this back up but I also
got a few emails yesterday saying David
why are you repeating these
unsubstantiated conspiracy theories
against Trump well hold on a second
there are rape allegations the lawsuit
was pulled over death threats Trump is
accused of sexually assaulting more than
15 women
he's accused of hanging out with Epstein
and young women Trump's wife said that
Trump raped her multiple times
what is so out of line here about the
fact that we have court documents and
deposition testimony from the accuser of
Donald Trump claiming she was 13 years
old when Donald Trump raped her are you
saying that because there was no
conviction in the Trump child rape there
is no reason to think anything happened
that seems like an extreme position to
take incredibly there are tons and tons
of people who just have no idea about
the sworn allegations against Donald
Trump but we have sworn statements from
the woman who was 13 at the time that
has not changed we are linking to her
deposition video where her face is
blurred in the source links for the
YouTube video for this segment if you
want to take a look at it if you're
listening on the radio or the podcast or
watching on TV if you go to our YouTube
channel youtube.com slash the David
Pakman show
find the video clip for this story in
the description we are linking to the
testimony of the accuser take a look at
it and tell me that it's not credible so
things not going particularly well for
Donald Trump and we will see what
continues to come of this and Donald
Trump very clearly worried about it
Donald Trump going out of his way to
talk about how he just barely has any
idea who Epstein is he gave a very
strange Oval Office a
question-and-answer session yesterday
where he's just going way too far he's
going way too far given what we know and
what's on record about his relationship
with Epstein let me know what you think
is going to come of this and of course
if history is an indicator the last two
and a half years are an indicator it is
unlikely that there will ever actually
be any consequences that in
Trump here because that seems to be the
name of the game Teflon Don originally I
can't believe the mobster I always
forget who it is that Teflon Don was
originally the nickname for and I feel
so stupid when people email me but
anyway can also be applied to Donald
Trump send me your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter a David Pakman show hope you'll
follow me there today's sponsor is
Skillshare and I'm excited to tell you
that everybody in our audience is
getting two entire months of free access
to Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video skill shares the
site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other 7 million users by clicking
the link underneath this video
[Music]